bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono fa vj egiziano tornati sud o
sud doctor dead
siamo tornati alla camicia che quanto
spettacolare è questo se avuto un al di
sotto del della spiaggia prima inter e
gale ultima volta ho fatto cenetta
romantica e adesso ragazzi siamo
all'ospedale domini che cosa parla
questa storia cos'è sta roba è una
storia su papa cosa posso muovermi può
dato che posa sexy è questa ragazzi ma
che ca come cassa panna cambia apostoli
è un infermiere è un infermiere qualcosa
delle infermiere va bene la facciamo con
sé da infermiere tipo buttare giù i
quadri e i vasi a caso devo andare al
bancone degli infermieri perfetto
ragazzi è una cosa giorno senza per caso
salehi dove si trova al bancone l
infermiera si faccia stringerli questo
abbraccio caso le piace vero grazie no
non posso seguirti però io ti amo lo
stesso ascolti le foto la tazza grazie
mille ragazzi sono sempre stato portato
per fare l'infermiere cioè guardatemi
come mi muovo in modo sicuro papa
incontro questo tipo che era
insopportabile il mio didietro fa ancora
male via giusti il letto scotto zio non
farmi cacciare perché ti riempio debola
devo imboccare sto deficiente
devo aggiustarli il letto fantastico
questo effetto di minori non salteranno
magicamente nella mia bocca amico mi
hotel infilo nel culo ecco come non
detto el inzuppo bene nelle tue mutande
così e poi tre magi perfetto ma chi è
bello il mio paziente che si prende
tutto nel dell'età nella piano piano a
prime nelle bambine eccolo qui che entra
tutto mi annoio mi porti urli provare
non se non sei contento dopo tutte
queste melo nino il culo portato a 100
205 un libro la portiamo un libro allo
ragazzi li prenderei il libro come come
espellere i meloni dal deretano credo le
dispiace se le rubo quest'anno perché
tanto non sta leggendo ora vivamente
ragazzi che si faccia le cose giuste
anche questo libro perché ha la scorta
missione io te lo do questo però ecco la
mia flebo e quasi vuota si sbrigherà
riempirla infermiera perché sono un non
lo so una sacca debora la vuoi che parte
non perché ha chiesto a riempirli la
flebo grazie dai a pazienza 205 una
nuova flebo
posso prendere questo grazie allora vado
subito a prenderle quella giusta per
casa perché tutti gli stacchi dalla mia
gamba brutta [ __ ] perfetto guardi è la
prenda lei non lo è
6 stronza proprio senti non è che padre
stile carla e poi papa incontra una
pazienza che si comporta stranamente non
sappiamo dove va a finire non è che te
la spalla mi fa eco bene il sudore lo
asciughiamo apra le camp nou per questo
risolve zio la senti l'hanno buttata nei
posti più brutti i possibili e adesso te
la tela infine cui si tolga di mezzo noi
abbastanza non sia tranquillo non ci
tengo a essere ammalato anch'io se non
le dispiace buon uomo per evitare il
contagio chiuderei anche la porta dove
stai attenta e sa perché a queste cose
della pressione
vediamo ecco qua perfetti sì sì sì sì sì
stiamo trampoli stylist escludendo il
braccio credo avranno già ok ok ok
perfetto e degli occhi e mi dice spetti
un secondo che controlliamo subito
sì sei [ __ ] posso la vedi questa torcia
bene adesso vedi la torcia quindi di
sicuro non sei ceca cosa si tratta sia
sincero infermiere ebola borbotta
termini scientifici molto specie
potrebbe farmi un disegno sulla lavagna
allora mia cara signora lei sa
esattamente questo è anno questa casa
mia la femmina in questo devo andare a
bere un attimo cos'è pochino questi sono
dei jeans quindi lei al agency the
capisco o la unicorni non è affatto male
grazie infermiere partenza cosa vuol
dire cosa cazzo è successo mia carissima
collegare andrebbe se lo frizzi un tempo
ferma cazzo tornerò un giorno 201
ragazzi fatemi entrare da 201 salve e
papà incontro questa tipa che era molto
gentile signor infermiere con giornalai
senta le caduto il vaso sono le cose
troppo disturbo le dispiacerebbe prima
charm il cuscino a spegnere la tv ispri
maggio tutto quello che voglio me
facciamo un cuscino ci sarà gente ma
guarda fuori dalla finestra del cazzo
pensa ecco a terzi a perfetto adesso
stai tranquilla devo spegnete la tv ma
facciamo così dimetto perché cazzo
ciambelle in sala d'attesa
ecco del denaro per comprarne alcune no
stai tranquilla già offro io a volte le
ciambelle alla paziente 201 vaiani ma
prende amia naturalmente mi chiamava
dato 300 dollari per delle cazzo di
ciambelle compriamo cia meglio l'ascolta
mica posso comprare le ciambelle
ecco qui alla prima prima perfetto
ho preso chubais cazzo prima stinca
frasca e scontati o la prende un attimo
e scusami nativo e son cadute perfetto
voglio essere un [ __ ] polipo per
poter fare questo è bellissimo non li
sapeva bene prendo anche quelli sotto
ecco la sorpresa lo portieri joe uno
stato estero nato stanno uscendo tutte
le ciambelle posso prenderne è linee
porto 1 e faccio prima veramente preso
delle ciambelle da passando da sotto una
macchinetta
io vorrei essere un polipo solo per far
stare ma ragazzi e bellissima ed ecco
lei ecco le perse ma di cosa si figuri
adesso aiutato to the ever
vorrei vedere il telefono squilla quanto
pizzeria o la terribile notizia darti un
altro pazienti sta avendo un arresto
cardiaco
allarme pazienza nella stanza 200 c ma
veramente devo andare a curare un
arresto cardiaco
appello di zio come sai non ascolta io
giuro che non sono stato io è proprio di
fico non stai facendo
cos'è stato trovato quest'uovo a terra
ascoltami io io so come curare lebbra
perché sono un infermiere provetto e se
esci e poi esci esci da questo corpo e
aveva beh dai pro proviamo a farlo un po
meglio è stata needs io non dovevo dare
posizione perfetta non guardi lei mentre
sto facendo queste cose brutte guardi
dall'altra parte per via fate largo sto
portando un paziente in sala operatoria
forza andiamoci toglierle levasse le
offre un paziente né emergerne
riparliamo dopo e ascolti ma
all'improvviso papa si trova ad
affrontare un terribile avversario se
riuscissi a passare da sta cazzo di una
porta ci sono passati per fortuna c'era
un piede di porco con cui forzarla ok a
posso forzare la porta per far passare
il paziente veloce velodromo voti la
ecco perfetto risveglio ziona perché
sono ti devo a dormire ecco perché un
piede di porco nel culo e non ha sentito
niente direi che è morto lavati le mani
come lavati le mani o ancora il possente
dietro million lavarle ma nota mi stai
stai lì bello buono buono mentre io mi
lavo le mani e poi sicuro perfetto bene
eccoci con perfetto nel culo di raccolta
inizia adesso siamo lavati sterilizzati
e tutto possiamo iniziare l'operazione
no perché c'è non è che posso stare qua
tutto già ascoltami
ecco qua perfetto bravo mettilo sul
tavolo del tino chiama al dottor nigel
che con mickey è quello di sergio
simulator 2 torna lì avremo numeri a
caso praticamente ai premuto tutti i
pulsanti a malta per il dottor nile e al
dottor legali sono scandalizzato sta
arrivando il dottore nel frattempo
attivasse team infilo questa cosa è un
tampax qualcosa del genere
dottore non sto facendo niente stavo
semplicemente perché fraternizzando col
paziente molti dottore famoso devo fare
una scansione a raggi si ma se faccio
tutto io che cazzo di dottore eccoci
eccoci annusa annusa che bello perfetto
ho preso l'attrezzo sbagliato mi perdoni
dottore ma sono un po distratto oggi
attore mi ascolti sto paziente a 3 kg di
anguria nel culo non è perché devo
prepararla queste cose
non va bene ok perfetto lo abbiamo
accesa fai una scansione all'agi ci
siamo porta nigel un bisturi pianista
bisturi fai quello che vuoi
ecco porta a nigel una sega lotta mi fai
tu perché tanto non sono io il dottor e
arrivare ora l'operazione fa si prepara
a compiere l'incisione meglio di noi
stessi papà mi ha messo in punizione una
settimana per l'ultima storia si ma
ragazzi mi spiegate il suo dottore visto
cazzo che cosa dovrebbe fare se faccio
ho appena toccato un essere umano e si è
trasformato in un cazzo di robot per cui
adesso l'operazione può cominciare ma
cosa posso operarlo ascoltami
tu sei il dottore famoso non io che
cazzo ci sto a fare qua io gliela stacco
proprio con le mani giusto vabbè
ripulisci la capitato rava be faccio
tutto io dai tolgo io fc si ami che ha
fatto un lavorone della madonna più di
così simili azioni se segando le gambe o
come fai
ma per chi sta segando braccia gambe e
tutto quello che non deve fare gli
pulisci la fronte anaide ariano lo
scottex intero proprio il budget e nel
suo petto trovano un cuore distrutto e
le sue braccia le gambe buono da tutte
le parti ma mio zio che casa visto che i
bambini film horror è l'operazione più
assurda che io abbia mai visto in tutta
la mia vita ma va bene ok il tifo non è
più roba è certo le fibrillazioni
ragazzi devo defibrillare il paziente
[Musica]
piano eccolo qua ci siano schiacciato il
carrello dopo è una cosa batti il cinque
nile è mai così e poi il dottore famoso
si batterono il 5 si ho capito però
metti il 76 una striscia una sedia a
rotelle va bene allora mettiamo facendo
scorta mi si ma è morto come cosa
facciamo sì allora ascoltami so se ti
schiaccia un attimo credo di averli
spezzato il collo ma sono solo
supposizioni perché stesse diavola
abbiate pazienza non ho mai non ho mai
visto al sì esattamente così dopo che è
seduto così in modo sexy come potrei non
portarlo nella sua stanza e non importa
essere polipi qualsiasi cosa
l'importante è saper fare i trapianti di
cuore ci siamo eccoci qua eccoli alla
prossima volta mi chiami e mi dici
rimetti mi il letto brutto stronzo però
si prese la uni cornet
ma no è l'unica cura per la unicorni te
sono le moto d'acqua
ovviamente così papa ci compro delle
moto da ho capito perche tu capito dove
andavi a parare 0 fine che è bella stona
ragazzi è stata la cosa più bella più
bella che io abbia mai giocato nella
storia no veramente abbiamo finito il il
dlc gli otto ragazzi questa era l'ultima
direi che possono chiudere video plus
fera che vi sia piaciuto anche perché
possano curare pazienti con 8 del però
va bene così
i ragazzi se non volete beccarmi
malattie vi basta a portare il rispetto
mentre io porto le angurie ai pazienti
ed i ragazzi servizio è piaciuto ma se
lasciato il commento mi piace anche a
pacelli facebook e come ogni video tata
nelle sezione se anche voi volete avere
il potere di prendere le ciambelle dalla
macchinetta senza c'è poco col break va
bene se dovessi descrivermi c diventiamo
il prossimo video bello ragazzi